even the most seemingly invincible bad
guys
usually succumb to the hero by the end
of the movie but the rare occasions they
don't
can make for a memorable experience be
warned
we're digging into spoilers galore in
the best movies where villains win
in the end a story with roots in history
the crucible takes place way back at the
end of the 17th century in colonial
america
in the sleepy town of salem
massachusetts yep
that's salem inspired by the salem witch
trials of historic legend
the film follows a group of young women
including abigail williams
played by winona ryder who has had an
affair with daniel day lewis's john
proctor
and literally wants to put a curse on
his wife in order to kill her off
and have proctor all to herself already
messed up in the special kind of way
that only real life scenarios can
provide
the situation begins to spin out of
control when abigail and the group of
girls are nearly caught practicing
witchcraft
and ultimately begin to accuse others to
save their own skin
of course taking place in puritan new
england
these kinds of things were not taken
lightly and anyone who is accused by the
supposedly innocent posse of girls
has to either confess or be executed the
film
ends with several characters including
jon proctor himself
refusing to confess and ultimately being
killed
talk about a depressing win for the
forces of evil
unlike a lot of horror flicks the
triumph of saw's villain comes as a
clever surprise
whether you're a fan of the franchise or
not it's hard not to be impressed by the
twist
ending that the first film in the series
delivered with jigsaw
rising up from the center of the room
bringing everyone's jaws
crashing to the ground while director
james wan's debut film was a horrifying
success
that doesn't change the fact that the
villain yet again wins without question
one of the first revelations of the film
is that the saws so helpfully provided
to the captive protagonists
are meant for cutting not metal but
flesh the climax becomes
increasingly tense as dr lawrence gordon
played by carrie elwis
slowly loses his mental stability but
even before the saws come into play
the string of events orchestrated by the
mysterious murderer are more than enough
to showcase that this
is a villain who knows how to win from
bear traps
to barbed wire and more jigsaw is one of
the most successful villains to ever
lay in a pool of fake blood on a
bathroom floor
the early 1970s were a dark time for
american movies
and chinatown is exemplary of that trend
the film is stylized like a noir
complete with a 1930s setting and a
complicated plot
involving water rights in california the
movie's plot
is ultimately fairly secondary to its
tone
which is despairing throughout in its
final moments
we see the death of the film's heroine
played by faye dunaway
and hear the film's signature line
forget it jake it's chinatown
the film's villain noah cross played by
john huston
gets away with his complicated scheme to
consolidate more power
what's more no one discovers that his
daughter who was the one who initially
opened the case with jack nicholson's
private investigator character
jake getz was someone he had abused
practically all her life
at the film's conclusion gitz fails to
protect her
and is forced to walk away from the
whole affair unsatisfied
chinatown is a grim film about the
realities of life
where a few powerful people can play
with the rest of us like pieces on a
chessboard
gitz tries his best to change things but
discovers that knowing the truth matters
less than having power
the coen brothers don't usually make
happy movies
but no country for old men is one of the
filmmaking duo's
bleakest it follows josh brolin's
llewellyn moss
as he makes off with a huge pile of cash
in the aftermath of a drug deal gone
wrong
he's pursued by javier bardem's anton
chigurh
a man relentlessly bent on recovering
the funds
shakur is a menacing figure who can
forget the infamous
coin flip scene
call it calling yes
just call it both moss and sugar
are also being pursued by tommy lee
jones character
sheriff tom bell who makes a vow to
protect moss that ultimately fails
sugar kills him off screen recovers the
money and walks away scot-free
no country for old men ends with belle
who has retired from the force as a
result of the violence he's seen
as he describes a dream he once had
about his father
and finding light in the darkness that
ending and the entirety of no country
for old men
suggests that light is an illusion
humanity lives in the darkness
and revels in it and bad people do bad
things and get away with them
anton chaguer isn't punished for his
crimes
he's brutal enough to do whatever he
wants
rosemary's baby follows mia farrow as
rosemary as she goes through her
pregnancy and the birth of her child
only to discover that she's delivered a
child of satan
the baby was part of a deal that her
husband drew up with their neighbors
who happened to worship the devil
throughout the film rosemary works to
uncover what's really going on with her
pregnancy
but in the end she fails to stop the
demonic scheme
what's more she seems to decide that
she's willing to love the child
anyway she was forced into this
pregnancy against her will
sold out by her husband completely her
child though
is still hers even if his dad is a bit
of a troublesome figure
the movie ends on the bleak idea that
rosemary can't do anything about her
situation
she's been tortured throughout the film
and her reward is a child she never
asked for evil wins out and rosemary is
left to pick up the pieces of a life
that other people have forced on her
if your wife tried to frame you for
killing her
would you take her back when she
returned most people would likely say no
but not ben affleck's nick dunn one of
the characters at the center of gone
girl
the movie follows nick in the aftermath
of his wife's disappearance
as evidence begins to pile up suggesting
he's the killer
as we learn midway through the film
though his wife amy played by rosamund
pike
has been setting him up the entire time
from there the movie tracks amy's
decision to return home
and her ultimate plan to trap nick and
their relationship
she's pregnant with his child and he
decides that he has to stay
to help raise it as amy the film's
ostensible villain
tells him he actually likes the life she
gives him
she's exciting and challenging and
that's what he wants
even if it means that he's occasionally
accused of murder
in the end of gone girl amy gets
everything that she wants
even though she's killed at least one
person along the way
few movies pull the rug out from
audiences as successfully as the usual
suspects
for most of its run time we think we're
getting a reliable version of the film's
events from kevin spacey's
verbal kent the only survivor of a
five-man crew
who decides to pull a robbery that goes
terribly awry
in the film's final moments though we
realize that verbal has been lying the
entire time
the film's villain a terrible criminal
known only as kaiser sose
is actually kent and the limp he's had
for the entire movie
is fake it's unclear how much truth
there is in the story that kent
tells but he ultimately escapes without
a scratch
he deceives everyone and the movie's
final moments are devoted to watching
kent
drive away having killed several people
without any sort of punishment
spacey's performance in the film won him
an oscar and it's easy to see why
there is a menace hiding underneath the
supposedly vulnerable hint
that becomes obvious as soon as you know
the twist kent is just telling a story
to get out of a tough bind
and the cops who are listening fall for
it hook line
and sinker erotic thrillers thrive on
the bizarre combination of sensual
tension and death threats
in basic instinct sharon stone and
michael douglas
balance those qualities perfectly the
film follows
douglas's erratic cop as he becomes
obsessed with stone's character
an author who is a suspect in a homicide
case in part because she wrote a book
that describes a very similar killing in
gruesome detail
douglas's obsession eventually
transforms into a romantic relationship
and audiences are never explicitly told
that stone's character is guilty
even so it's easy to put the pieces
together and realize that she's likely
gotten away with several killings over
the course of the film
possibly before as well all of that
becomes more evident in the film's
closing moments
as we see that stone's author has
considered killing douglas's cop
using the same method as in the death at
the start of the film
basic instinct is a filthy neo-noir in
every sense of the word
while we don't know for sure who the
murderer really is
it certainly seems like someone has
gotten off easy as the movie
reaches its conclusion the alien movies
are generally fairly bleak affairs
in the first couple though protagonist
ellen ripley gets out of danger by the
end
even if there are heavy casualties along
the way by the time ridley scott got
around to directing
alien covenant that had changed unlike
most previous alien movies though
the villain of covenant isn't a
xenomorph but an android named
david played by michael fassbender who
was first introduced in the preceding
film
prometheus in this movie we learned that
david is the xenomorph's creator
and we watch as he slowly picks off the
crew of the ship that has discovered it
although several crew members do survive
the film
david undoubtedly emerges victorious and
successfully escapes the planet where he
was stranded
he's going to spread xenomorphs all over
the galaxy and one of those very same
aliens will eventually terrorize ripley
and her crew
on the nostromo david's victory in this
film is not just bleak because of what
it means about covenant
but also because of what it foretells
about the rest of the alien universe
one flew over the cuckoo's nest is about
a rebel who loses
the film stars jack nicholson as randall
mcmurphy a new patient at a mental
institution who pleaded insanity
in order to avoid hard labor while
imprisoned once he arrives
he discovers that the hospital is being
run under the strict supervision of
nurse ratchet and decides that he wants
to challenge her rule
the film chronicles mcmurphy's attempts
to rile the other patients at the
institute up
in defiance of nurse ratchet
[Applause]
ultimately though mcmurphy's attempts at
defiance fail
at the end of one flew over the cuckoo's
nest it's determined that the only way
the threat mcmurphy poses
can be neutralized is if he is
lobotomized in the film's final scene
chief a character who is believed to be
non-verbal throughout most of the film
only to be revealed to be basically
faking it asphyxiates mcmurphy with a
pillow
and escapes from the institute although
chief gets away with his life
mcmurphy the rebel at the film's center
does not
nurse ratchet quashes his attempt to get
himself and his fellow patients more
freedom
and dies ratchet's tyrannical rule over
the facility remains
the cabin in the woods is something of
an exception on this list
the villains undoubtedly win but they do
so with the help of the movie's
protagonists
the cabin in the woods is an explicit
riff on horror movie tropes
as five friends head to the country to
spend the weekend in a creepy abandoned
cabin
what they don't know is that they are
actually human sacrifices in an annual
ritual
the ritual has specific rules that
happen to align with those of a horror
movie
and requires that at least four of the
five friends die in the cabin
if the friends don't die mythical forces
from the underworld will return to earth
and wipe out mankind
when the main characters discover this
though they decide not to play along
instead of agreeing to act as sacrifices
they decide that humanity
should be doomed the ritual fails and
the titans return to earth
as a result the film's human villains
the people who were trying to sacrifice
our main characters
lose watchmen is based on some pretty
depressing
source material and zack snyder's 2009
adaptation doesn't do much to mess with
that tone although the adaptation does
change
some things the basic plot of the
graphic novel remains intact
the death of a superhero spurns an
investigation that ultimately unveils a
plot
hatched by matthew goods ozymandias the
smartest man on the planet
ozymandias plan is to avert an
apocalyptic event by creating one on a
much
smaller scale in the movie this event is
a radioactive explosion that he plans to
blame on dr manhattan
uniting the us and soviet union against
him
ultimately the rest of the superheroes
agree that azamandius's plan
is the best course of action if an
apocalypse is to be avoided
the plan requires the deaths of millions
but it goes off without a hitch
and ozymandias believes that he'll be
justified in the end
both the movie and the graphic novel
suggest that the plan
may not be the success that he imagines
it to be but they allow him to carry it
out anyway
he wins and his victory means death and
destruction
the original 1973 version of the wicker
man
ends with human sacrifice as all great
horror movies
should the film follows a devout
christian detective named neil howie
who visits a small hybridian island as
part of a search for a missing girl
while on the island howie becomes
horrified by the pagan rituals that he
sees practiced
ultimately he determines that the
missing girl is meant to be a human
sacrifice
and infiltrates the islander's ceremony
in order to rescue her after escaping
with her though
it's revealed that she was just a ruse
to draw howie to the island
howie was always intended to be the
human sacrifice
as the sacrifice has to meet certain
criteria and he meets all of them
the movie ends with our hero detective
being burned alive
alongside a variety of animal sacrifices
playing on the paranoia caused by
terrorist bombers in the 1990s
arlington road is about suspecting that
your neighbors are terrorists
and ultimately finding out that you're
right the movie follows michael faraday
as he meets his new neighbors and begins
to suspect that they're lying about
their lives
ultimately he discovers that they're
part of a terrorist organization
and their goal is to blow up part of an
fbi building located near their
neighborhood
although michael attempts to warn the
authorities about the incoming attack
his neighbors are ahead of him at every
turn ultimately a bomb does go off
but the bomb has been planted in the
back of michael's car
because michael was at the fbi building
to warn them it blows part of that
building up
and michael appears to be the lone wolf
responsible for the explosion
michael's neighbors meanwhile get away
scot-free and move to another suburb
where they can find someone else to
blame for their latest attack
there aren't really any good guys in ex
machina
but that doesn't mean that the villain
doesn't ultimately win the day
the movie tells the story of donald
gleason's low-level computer programmer
named caleb
who travels to a tech billionaire's
house in order to test his advanced
artificial intelligence
basically the whole film exists in a
moral grey area
ava the artificial intelligence seems
kind and gentle
but obviously resents the cage she has
been placed in by her creator
eventually ava escapes that cage killing
her billionaire creator
and trapping caleb inside her former
home the movie treats her escape with
the sense of dread
and although she sends some characters
to their doom it's hard not to feel at
least part of yourself
rooting for ava she's been trapped by
mankind for the entirety of ex machina
and in the end she finally gets a chance
to break free
if you're just looking at its premise
inside man really shouldn't work
the movie which tells the story of bank
robbers and the cops who are trying to
stop them
spends much of its running time hyping
up the genius of the robbery plot at its
center
at times it seems like the head robber
played by clive owen
is losing control of his carefully
constructed plan
and because the cop in charge of
stopping him is played by denzel
washington
it can be pretty hard to imagine the
robbery going successfully
in the end though our robber gets away
with it he hides inside the bank for
days after the initial robbery
waiting for the right moment to casually
exit the building with all the money
he's stolen
it's a shockingly simple plan one that
only requires
some determination on his part
washington's cop steps away from the
crime realizing there is an entire
rigged system that he's operating within
at the end of the day owen's character
gets away with it because the cop
charged with stopping him
stopped caring mr glass the villain at
the heart of unbreakable
believes in the archetypes that comic
books establish he knows he's a villain
and that david dunn exists to oppose him
the movie's twist
isn't that glass has pulled off some
major scheme what we discover
is that he's been a terrorist this
entire time and that his ultimate goal
was to uncover
other people with special abilities like
his glass gets away with his plot
because he carries it out before the
movie
even really begins he discovers david in
the process
and while david ultimately imprisons him
he's actually doing
exactly what glass wants him to glass's
only
goal was to find a hero to oppose him
and he's done that by discovering david
he never wanted to escape from his plan
without consequences
he wants to fulfill his comic book
fantasy with everything that might
entail
matt damon has a range he doesn't get to
show off much these days
in the talented mr ripley though we see
damon play a psychopath with a chilling
skill
the movie follows damon's tom ripley a
low-class man who rises up the ranks of
young high society in the 1950s
thanks to a relationship with jude law's
dickie greenlee
a wealthy aimless young man ultimately
tom's love for
and jealousy of dickie proves too
powerful
and he kills him at sea instead of
confessing to his crime though
tom takes over dickie's life and all of
the wealth that it entails
tom spends the rest of the film trying
desperately not to get caught
and he succeeds he gets away with that
murder
and another one tom ripley may not be a
good person
but he is very good at what he does and
he proves that at the end of the
talented mr ripley
the vanishing is an effective thriller
because of the toll it inflicts on a
harmless protagonist
the story follows a couple saskia and
rex
who are on a trip together when the two
of them pull over at a rest stop
saskia goes into the station to buy
something and vanishes
rex frantically searches for her but is
never able to find her
years later rex is confronted by
sasuke's kidnapper
raymond the man who kidnapped and
eventually killed saskia
tells rex that he knew from a young age
that he didn't have
any conscience in fact his decision to
kidnap saskia came as he was trying to
determine whether doing bad things
felt any different to him than doing
good deeds
eventually he tells rex that the only
way he'll be able to learn what happened
to sasukiya is by
experiencing it himself the two returned
to the rest stop where saskia originally
vanished
and raymond drugs rex when he wakes up
rex finds that raymond has buried him
alive
raymond meanwhile is living a quiet
peaceful life with his family
he's gotten away with killing two people
and he doesn't feel a thing
satan is usually a hard villain to
overcome
that much is obvious in the omen a
classic horror film for many reasons
but one is undoubtedly its bleak ending
the film tells the story of a couple who
unknowingly adopt the antichrist
a young boy named damian robert thorne
damien's father spends much of the movie
trying to determine where his adopted
son
actually came from along the way a
number of people die
under questionable circumstances look at
me damien
it's all for you as the movie approaches
its climax
damian's adopted mother is killed by his
nanny
and when robert discovers that his wife
has been killed he stabs the nanny to
death then he takes damian to a church
and places him on the altar
only to be shot down by police before he
can kill his demonic son
the movie ends with a joint funeral for
damien's adopted family
damien himself cracking a smile by the
end of the omen
evil has conquered good and everyone who
knows what damian really is
has already ended up in the ground
when you watch brazil things are not
exactly what they seem
the movie follows a low-level government
worker named sam
who spends much of his time thinking
about a woman who comes to him in dreams
ultimately sam becomes embroiled in a
complicated conspiracy after discovering
that a bureaucratic error
has led to the arrest and death of the
wrong man that discovery leads sam down
a path to find the woman he's been
seeing in his dreams who is named
jill when he learns that jill is
considered a terrorist accomplice
because she attempted to report the
wrongful arrest
sam creates false records so she can
escape
after sharing a romantic night together
the two are arrested
and sam is strapped to a chair where he
is about to be tortured
before the torture can begin though a
resistance force
breaks into the building and rescues sam
and jill
in the movie's final moments though we
learned that the rescue mission was all
a delusion of sam's broken mind
we see that he is still trapped to the
chair and it's heavily implied that he
has been lobotomized
sam may dream of escaping the
bureaucracy that controls every aspect
of his life
but in reality it's a system that's
impossible to escape from
another horror entry creep's ending is
dark and definitive
this found footage film tells the story
of aaron a videographer who has been
hired by a man named
joseph to film a video diary in a remote
cabin
joseph tells aaron that he has an
inoperable brain tumor
and wants to film a diary for his
daughter who will be born after he dies
joseph displays strange behavior
throughout the movie
and aaron ultimately receives a call
from joseph's sister
urging him to leave the house as soon as
possible the two scuffle but aaron gets
away
and begins getting videotapes from
joseph following his departure
aaron realizes that joseph is stalking
him and joseph eventually
offers to meet aaron in a public park in
order to make peace
as a precaution aaron decides to keep a
camera on himself
joseph comes up from behind aaron while
he's sitting on a bench
and kills him with an axe joseph reviews
the footage aaron collected following
his death
and realizes that aaron must have
thought he was a good person
the movie ends as joseph moves on to his
next kill
and puts aaron's film on the shelf with
the rest of his victims
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one